he's played a young Mandalorian and a
Tuscan Raider this celebrity's nephew is
carving out a spot for himself in Star
Wars and so much more as if there
weren't enough reasons to check out the
book of Boba Fett Star Wars fans needed
to watch it to understand what's going
on in the Mandalorian season 3. over the
course of a couple of episodes we see
din jarin getting exiled from the
Mandalorian way he's also reunited with
his little buddy grogu who's been
learning the ways of the Jedi basically
it sets up everything you need to know
going into a new season of the
Mandalorian needless to say the first
episode of season 3 really kicks things
off with a bang the episode opens with a
traditional Mandalorian baptism ceremony
the armorer crafts a helmet for a young
Mandalorian child who is eagerly
awaiting this rite of passage
unfortunately the ceremony is
interrupted by a giant monster as often
happens in a galaxy far far away but the
monster may not have been the only thing
to catch your attention the child
getting baptized may have looked
familiar to you especially if you tune
into a lot of Disney plus Originals the
young actor's name is Wesley Kimmel and
that last name is no coincidence he is
indeed the nephew of late night talk
show host Jimmy Kimmel but he's quickly
becoming an actor in his own right
whereas Lee's resumes building up nicely
while he initially appeared periodically
on episodes of Jimmy Kimmel life he
since popped up in various films and TV
shows including the rookie and good
girls however he appears to be carving
out a nice niche for himself on Disney
plus he stars as a commercial boy in a
few episodes of One Division and he
played a Tuscan kid on the first three
episodes of The Book of Boba Fett he
must have made a good impression on
somebody as now he's rejoined Star Wars
for chapter 17 of the Mandalorian most
recently Wesley Kimmel could be found
playing Jack in the Netflix original
film your place or mine starring Reese
Witherspoon and Ashton Kutcher it's also
been confirmed that he'll appear in the
upcoming Amazon Prime video movie red
one so he's certainly keeping busy these
days it was dope my mom would never let
me watch that Wesley's inclusion in two
Star Wars properties is made possible by
the fact that viewers didn't get a
chance to see his face in the book of
Boba Fett he's a child Tuscan Raider and
as such she wears a mask obstructing his
face for any scenes he's featured in
this makes it easy for the young actor
to come back to play a Mandalorian child
in the Mandalorian season 3. in many
ways the book of Boba Fett turned into
the Mandalorian season 2.5 thanks to the
inclusion of fan favorites Mando and
grogu but one thing it did exceptionally
well was flesh out the Tuscan Raiders as
actual characters as opposed to plot's
father and they played an integral role
in Boba Fett's Journey Rory Ross who
plays one of the Tuscan Raiders on the
show opened up about what it was like to
be part of such a massive Star Wars
property in an interview with Lupa Ross
actually gave a shout out to the young
Kimmel for playing the Tuscan kid
pointing out how important the character
was for Boba Fett's Arc Russ told Looper
the little Tuscan kid played by Wesley
Kimmel represents Boba as a child and
him his innocence and everything else
when his father passes away and we'd see
that on Geonosis in episode 2. it
remains to be seen if the Mandalorian
child will factor into the larger
machinations of the show during season
three however it's already clear that
Wesley Kimmel is proving to be a
valuable asset to Disney
[Music]